[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias muchas gracias gracias te
escucho claramente estamos transmitiendo
en este momento en vivo desde la
república democrática del congo que
estoy haciendo aquí bueno estamos
atendiendo a una es un llamado del
reporte del gobierno de la república del
congo en donde nos dicen que este es el
día en que va a cambiar la historia de
la humanidad no entendemos por qué pero
pues bueno este es un paraíso tropical
es increíble lleno de junglas lagos
enormes es una cosa increíble les
explico que lo que estoy viendo frente
de mí ahí bueno pues hay muchísima
seguridad hay aproximadamente un millar
de militares mil militares fácilmente
enfrente de nosotros hay una especie de
quiero pensar es una caja gigante muy
grande unos 810 metros de altura
bueno podría ser un mini edificio a lo
mejor y bueno pues hay muchos militares
rodeando está esta gran caja y bueno
pues hay también militares en frente de
nosotros ahí les aproximadamente unos
500 militares que no nos quitan la vista
y más bueno supongo que es por por algo
y la condición por el cual estamos aquí
para que podamos estar aquí es que no
podemos tomar ni vídeo ni tomar
fotografías tampoco somos un medio de
comunicación pero no lo podemos ver lo
entiendo está un anfitrión hablando con
un altavoz dirigiéndose a nosotros en su
idioma yo supongo que nos está dando la
bienvenida
ya se cayó se cayó el anfitrión ahora
están sonando especie de fanfarrias se
está empezando a desplazar hacia arriba
hay una gran luna que está cubriendo
este esta caja o no sé lo que sea ya se
empieza a desplazar hacia arriba con el
logo de la republica del congo y empieza
a verse lo que hay detrás de una jaula
permítanme es una jaula es una gran
jaula no sé lo que nos vayan a mostrar
santo cielo madre mía de dios
señores esto va a sonar bien loco estoy
viendo un dinosaurio un dinosaurio y
está vivo está vivo es demasiado
perfecto para ser un robot yo no sé
mucho de dinosaurios pero es el de las
dos grandes patas y sus bracitos
estaba muy nervioso es una fenomenal
bestia gigantesca muy nerviosa está
asustado los hay militares que le están
picando con unos enormes bastones
electrificados está enfureciendo
tremendamente el animal estamos
empezando a ponernos algo nerviosos con
sus fauces está tratando de arrancar uno
de los varias arrancó un barrotes de la
jaula señores ya lo arrancó
estamos un poquito nerviosos aquí me
está diciendo el soldado bueno quiero
que entender que me está diciendo que
está todo bajo control seguro
mis compañeros ya empiezan a estar
intranquila arrancó otro barrotes
señores
la bestia está muy molesta mis
compañeros y algunos ya empiezan a
correr e higüey no les puedo insultando
estoy en lo que se espere
pero a ver parece ser que bueno
esto está perdiendo toda tranquilidad
señores en un momento más me voy a
comunicar con ustedes país el de
ministro con su seguridad ya me voy
dígale a mi familia que la amo por favor
gracias traté de comunicarme con ustedes
son momentos más gracias
cuántos de los de aquí están presentes
en esta audiencia lograron retratar en
su mente todo esto que le narré levanten
la mano
se dan cuenta del poder de la
imaginación es increíble todo lo que la
imaginación puede lograr cosas
extraordinarias justamente esto es lo
que les voy a pedir vamos a utilizar la
imaginación durante esta charla el día
de hoy
qué les parece si seguimos imaginando
vamos a imaginar que vivimos en una gran
burbuja y enorme en esta burbuja hay una
sociedad completamente distinta a la que
conocemos es otra sociedad no como la
conocemos ok
imaginemos la ahora por favor retengan
ese pensamiento de esa imagen al final
de la charla ok guarden la un ratito
yo trabajo en un medio de comunicación
donde muchas de las ocasiones se utiliza
la imaginación yo trabajo en la radio
aunque la radio de hoy ya no es tan
invisible como antes
antes gozábamos de esa de esos tintes de
misterio no hay cómo será el cebado que
está hablando
ya no ahora ya con las aplicaciones con
las tecnologías nuevas ya es otra
historia sin embargo hay casos yo
conozco de casos de personas que se
niegan a utilizar esos avances y siguen
echando a volar su imaginación bueno en
mi caso por ejemplo me ha sucedido a mí
cuando yo estoy en alguna locación
haciendo enlaces de control remoto no
falta la persona que llega ahí
o las no lo conocía
desde que está la cosa
es que es muy diferente a como me lo
imaginé
a qué bueno
yo pensé que era un poco más jovencito
hombre me gustó el vino
gracias
esta persona echó a volar su imaginación
se imaginó otra cosa totalmente que no
era y me dio a mí yo no te remendar
mente
pero bueno vamos a cerrarlo vamos a
imaginarse en seguir utilizando la
imaginación vamos a imaginar una cabina
de radio esto es una situación
buenas noches
bienvenidos a su programa secreto de la
pasión
secretos de la capacidad
el único programa que es capaz de hacer
liberarte
el único programa donde tú y yo podemos
fundirnos en uno solo y llegar hasta lo
más hasta se agarra el button
secretos de la pasión llámame
y vamos a fundirnos en uno solo
y mientras te animas yo voy a un corte
comercial
y al regresar esperaré ansioso tu
llamada
secretos de la pasión
corte
i
y
bueno
qué pensamiento
aquí está jalando la noche si se enojó
al gerente conmigo me manda la noche
cuando le hace estallido así decide a
ver qué trampa respecto efe
voy a ver que te cuentas orienta abierto
no tengo hambre los tacos una
hamburguesa a ver que te encuentras si
lo que sea más que sin chiste conmigo
porque tal vez que después en chile me
produce gases no vayas es que ahorita al
aire se me salga toda mi furia
sí
sí sí
secreto se vigila los contrastes
si ustedes son fans de la radio y bueno
se llegan a topar con una situación así
por favor les sugiero
es tiene volar su imaginación pero
hágalo de una manera mesurada
porque uno se lleva cada sorpresa
me ha pasado
bueno
tienes que a los locutores mucha gente
nos puede llegar a creer todo lo que les
decimos cómo se los decimos de qué
manera se los decimos pero si lo creen
porque nosotros somos actores también
tal vez es nuestra obligación ser
actores él es práctico esto porque les
voy a platicar una anécdota
completamente cierta no es chiste es
cierta
resulta que cuando yo conocí a la que
ahora es mi esposa cuando yo la
pretendía yo en la radio utilizó un
personaje que es gay de mayair y
entonces su familia me tenía muy bien
ubicado
no nos tranquilos así no
ya sabían quién era yo entonces
ella se lo comunica a la familia en una
familia
qué creen
jairo anda tras mis huesos
el primero en saltar fue el hermano
ya hay luz
si es gay
como no se le nota al bato además hasta
cuando manejás
pipí se nota
tan loca que estás muy grande cita para
saber lo que haces no cuentes conmigo
como nada
ya europa
no cuentes conmigo total que hay si eso
la discusión se viene el día de la
presentación o sea mi presentación de su
familia y al primero que me presentan es
a la hermana
entonces ahora este mira él es mi
hermano
yo lo que más no está haciendo nada
no no
ganando me faltaron de hacerles
aprovechar el momento
bueno pero así como no nos llevamos
sorpresas tan desagradables o nos
divertimos con la imaginación
aunque ustedes no lo crean utilizando
esta herramienta que tal vez es muy
simple la imaginación podemos podemos
forjar un cambio en nuestra sociedad que
es lo que suena esto no y aquí viene el
punto serio de mi charla
oh my car
hace muchos años muchísimos años yo
siempre me he preguntado por qué tenemos
que estar acostumbrados a vivir dentro
de una sociedad enferma
en méxico en muchos países de
latinoamérica y en el mundo hay una
sociedad enferma porque tenemos que ver
tan normal de repente que ya llega
alguien a platicarnos el ataque al súper
ya la moral le pague con un billete de
veinte y medio cambio de 500
este mismo locutor desapareció sería si
no entonces me dio me cambio de 500 y la
satánica que padre
y se lo festejamos
o alguien que andan en la tienda en la
tienda de autoservicio va con su carrito
y oferta pantallas lcd 55 pulgadas 6
pesos sólo por hoy y el button
nudos una y otra y llegará desde el
carrito pues para llevarnos todos los
pantalones
y se hace el inteligente porque es bueno
esto se agarra a un hombre ya se
equivocó el monito que está etiquetando
aprovechemos 09 10
para que pueda venderlo
somos inteligentes al hacer esto yo me
pregunto por qué a veces vamos por
ejemplo a las conferencias de los
motivadores y nos platica de aquellos de
aquellos países tan lejanos de su esos
hábitos y costumbres tan distintos a los
nuestros donde su por ejemplo en japón
en su cultura está forjada desde que son
niños y se comportan completamente
diferentes a nosotros
y nos admiramos
y los vemos de lejos porque tenemos que
verlos de lejos y admirar los cientos no
podemos ser un poquito así parecidos
físicamente nos es imposible pero en la
manera de ser no nos podemos parecer un
poquitito nada más salimos de las
conferencias bien motivados
ya soy otro
nos vemos a tú no no me digas arturo de
memoria
ya soy otro
vamos nos subimos al carro
al auto lo aprendemos no hay tráfico no
hay tránsito 2000 agentes de vialidad el
semáforo el semáforo está en rojo
nos lo pasamos y todo eso que admiramos
durante algunos dos horas
de valldemossa
por qué
bien vamos a imaginar ahora que de
repente un poder divino cae sobre
nosotros
y nos quita todos esos hábitos malos que
tenemos y nos convierte en otras
personas vamos a imaginar lo bien
imaginar no provoca impuestos todavía
a cada día la regué per me volví a los
no dije eso no lo dije
caray
me van a odiar más que papeles miguel
pero vamos a imaginar ya lo dijo ese
sabio pensador filósofo intelectual
mexicano javier el chicharito hernández
cuando dijo
imaginemos cosas chingón as
lástima que la malva se imaginó no lo
dijo no no no la llevó a cabo
en esta cultura del agandalle que
tenemos tan arraigada podemos ir
eliminando eso de a poco de qué manera
bueno vamos pensando en los chiquitos en
los niños nuestros no se debe sin hitos
sobrinitos hijos no se nietos y que
ellos nos vean lo mejor que tenemos de
nosotros porque no los vamos a entrar
también mi hijo tienes que portarse bien
muy siempre en línea
mejor que nos vean ellos nos ven y
aprenden lo mejor de nosotros si bien
algo malo de nosotros bueno pues vamos a
utilizar la imaginación para revertir
esa situación claro que se puede por
supuesto que se puede es una herramienta
muy simple la imaginación
vamos a usándolo así
qué les parece si al final
cuando vayamos a casa
vamos haciendo un autoanálisis de cada
uno de nosotros vamos haciendo un conteo
de nuestros hábitos
nuestros malos hábitos nuestros buenos
hábitos no van a empezar con get a ver
yo pago impuestos y no
el pagar impuestos no es un acto de
bondad es una obligación en este y en
prácticamente todos los países del mundo
vamos a hacer un análisis llegamos a
casa nos paramos frente al espejo
y entonces si vamos a utilizar ese
pensamiento que yo les pedí que
guardaran al principio
y se pregunta
yo encajaría en una sociedad perfecta
no encajaría en una sociedad de primer
mundo
si la respuesta es sí
hombre
y si la respuesta es no bueno pues vamos
a usando nuestra imaginación y lo
volteamos en un sí y así podemos empezar
suena loco no pero se puede por supuesto
vamos a utilizar así el poder de la
imaginación muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]